Nos dicen: "Escribe 7 centésimas como una fracción
y como un decimal". Tomen lápiz y papel y traten
de resolver esto por su cuenta antes de que lo
resolvamos juntos. Primero vamos a escribirlo
como fracción. ¿Cuál será el denominador de esta
fracción? Nos piden 7 centésimas, y lo digo así
para darles una pista: 7 centésimas. Creo que
ya se dieron una idea, se trata de centésimas,
vamos a escribirlo: el denominador es 100
y ¿cuántas centésimas tenemos? Pues tenemos
7. Vamos a usar un color diferente para que
quede claro. Son 7 centésimas, y ya lo tenemos,
es esto expresado como una fracción. ¿Y cuál es
su expresión decimal? Pensemos en las posiciones
de los decimales, esta es la posición de las
unidades, escribimos un espacio en blanco en
este lugar, a un lado tenemos el punto decimal,
aquí está la posición de las décimas y esta es la
posición de las centésimas. Queremos representar
7 centésimas. Para que todo quede claro,
aquí están las unidades, aquí las décimas y acá
las centésimas. Me es divertido decirlo así:
centésimas, unidades, décimas y centésimas.
¿Cuántas unidades tenemos? Ninguna unidad,
0 unidades. ¿Cuántas décimas tenemos? No hay
décimas. ¿Cuántas centésimas tenemos? Tenemos
7 centésimas. Ok, ya no es tan divertido
pronunciarlo así, 7 centésimas, así que lo
escribimos así. Si queremos escribirlo un poco más
claro, lo escribimos así: 0 unidades, 0 décimas,
7 centésimas. Resolvamos otro ejemplo. Aquí
nos dicen "Selecciona la forma escrita de cada
número". Del lado izquierdo tenemos diferentes
representaciones, tenemos números escritos como
decimal, como fracción y como otro decimal, y
queremos relacionar cada número con su forma
escrita aquí arriba, donde tenemos combinaciones
de números y palabras. Pausen el video y traten
de resolverlo. Al ver el primer número de aquí
nos damos cuenta de que no tiene unidades y al
movernos una posición a la derecha del punto
decimal tenemos la posición de las décimas,
podemos ver que hay 4 de esas décimas aquí, este
número es 4 décimas, que corresponde a esta opción
de acá. Lo rellenamos, o si resuelven esto en el
portal de Khan Academy sólo tienen que hacer clic
sobre él para rellenarlo. ¿Qué hay con este?
Aquí lo leemos como 4 de 10 o 4/10, por lo que
esto corresponde a la misma opción, 4 décimas; lo
rellenamos también. Ahora veamos la última opción:
no hay unidades, no hay décimas, pero sí hay 4
centésimas. Lo volví a decir así, es divertido:
4 centésimas corresponde con esta columna, por lo
que rellenamos esta opción. Con esto terminamos.